donc pour comprendre comment l'agression
a été vécue de l'intérieur nous recevons
ce soir le co-président du centre LGBTI
de Touraine bonjour Quentin Boutet
alors bienvenue c'est la sixième
agression cette année avant on était sur
des dégradations matérielles cette
fois-ci on vise vos salariés et vos
membres comment vont-ils
comme on a pu le voir aussi dans le dans
l'interview c'est
ça va mieux que ce que moi j'aurais pu
penser si j'avais été à leur place je
pense
ils sont franchement ils se ils sont
vraiment bien et ça aurait pu être fier
en fait aussi parce que là du coup comme
on le disait il y avait que des dégâts
matériels mais de toute façon on reste
très vigilant auprès de notre équipe
salariée et nos bénévoles et on veille
aussi ce que à leur bien-être etc donc
si cela si pour le moment ça va on reste
quand même très à l'écoute au cas où ça
irait moins bien un jour vous avez porté
plainte ce matin comme pour chaque
vandalisation qui a eu lieu est-ce que
vous avez une idée au final de
l'auteur de l'identité de l'auteur de
ces menaces diverses qui ont eu lieu
nous avons toujours pas de d'idées
concrète en fait sur l'identité des
personnes qui ou de la personne en fait
qui s'en prend à nous de manière
successive
on pense tout de même que tous les
attaques sont liés mais on en est pas
sûr pour le moment on n'a pas d'éléments
suffisamment concrets pour pouvoir
identifier des personnes ou au moins une
personne et ses agressions elle pose la
question de la sécurité de vos salariés
de vos bénévoles et des personnes qui
sollicitent l'association
Emmanuel Denis le maire de Tours était
venu en avril pour parler de la
sécurisation du local est-ce que au-delà
des promesses il y a eu des choses
concrètes qui ont été faites ou qui vont
être faites des choses ont été faites
par exemple on a eu on n'a pas encore
les caméras plus solides et mieux
placées aussi comme vous pouvez l'avoir
avant là on a une caméra flottante aussi
qui est toujours là et que on peut être
utilisé durant durant l'enquête est en
cours
les vitrines ont été changées
aujourd'hui et avec ont été renforcés
est-ce que c'est
bien nous verrons bien si c'est
suffisant aujourd'hui comme en fait on
nous l'a annoncé aussi il y aura plus de
patrouille autour du local et après il y
a d'autres choses qui vont arriver plus
tard pour comme le rideau de fer qui
devrait arriver dans quelques mois mais
ça faut le temps de la production donc
forcément pour pas arriver plus vite
et sinon on a pris des dispositions en
interne pour être sûr que il y ait des
choses qui puisse être faites et qu'on
puisse maintenir nos actions parce qu'on
y tient parce qu'il faudrait pas laisser
gagner quand même nous au pressaires
donc
l'idée que lequel sera un peu plus fermé
parce qu'on sera plus selon vérifiera
plus les personnes qui rentrent aussi
enfin pour être sûr que d'assurer aussi
la protéine de bénéficiaires aussi pour
pouvoir maintenir nos actions qui sont
importantes est-ce qu'au final c'est pas
plus simple
peut-être de déménager de local parce
que avant vous étiez derrière la gare
vous aviez on entendait moins parler de
d'agression sur le local que maintenant
je sais je suis pas sûr que ça soit une
idée du changement de local je sais que
de ce que pour avait discuter avec H
clabot le cofondateur de l'association
que il y a déjà eu des actes avant je
sais pas si on en parlait autant parce
que j'étais pas sur toi mais
je pense aussi que c'est lié c'est pas
forcément lié au fait qu'on soit plus
exposé
en étant sur les arcades près des bords
de Loire mais plus aussi du fait qu'il y
a aussi une hausse des violences en fait
autour de l'orientation sexuelle des
antisettures de manière générale au
niveau mondiale européen même au niveau
local on le voit bien et donc je pense
que c'est surtout lié ça aussi et à la
banalisation par exemple des idées
d'extrême droite toujours des choses
plus que le fait qu'on ait changé de
local donc c'est plus il y a pas de
d'idées à ce qu'on change de local parce
qu'on est très bien là où on est et on
continue de rester et surtout que
peut-être un retour en arrière en terme
de visibilité
ce serait un retour en arrière et
surtout que ça serait un retour en
arrière même en termes de moyens parce
que le local de la guerre était beaucoup
plus petit on pouvait pas en fait avoir
d'espace de confidentialité si on veut
avoir des entretiens individuels donc
non non on est très très bien là où on
est et on veut y rester et puis
l'Amérique campagne nous déloger parce
que elle trouve ça très bien là où on
est aussi
merci Quentin beauté